the back channels that we knew about i
mean i'm sure you saw the video from a
couple months ago when jen saki admitted
that the administration flags
misinformation from facebook i mean they
were already infringing on our first
amendment rights they were already
having some coordination with companies
to limit our ability to speak uh you're
a journalist we don't really have any
journalists left anymore i mean that i
don't have to go like this you know do
the air quotes um why didn't more
journalists you'd think that journalists
might care about the first amendment why
didn't more journalists say uh maybe we
should look into that that the
government telling uh corporations what
can be said on their platforms is a bit
of a problem
yeah yeah well because in their mind
misinformation disinformation dangerous
speech all of these things that they
have sort of an objective criteria for
and and their objective criteria is
anybody that deviates from the
mainstream liberal orthodoxy that is
considered misinformation and we're
talking about vaccines about police
shootings whatever it is
like this thing happens over and over
again um that we see these same patterns
of
censorship i mean with the new york post
story on the hunter biden laptop that
was blocked from sharing on twitter i
mean that is egregious like if you just
read that you would think that that is a
story from like iran or some like
dictatorship or venezuela or something
but that was in the united states that
is deeply
disturbing
um and also i don't know if you want me
to push a little bit to what's happening
in canada as well like i'm i'm happy
that i'm happy this board is being
dismantling on your side because nina
jankowicz is deliberately um or
or i should say very um disturbing in
nature what what she was proposing in
her other weird tic-tac videos and what
not but here here in canada that trudeau
is pushing bill c-36 the the online
harms bill that's designed to protect
ethnic minorities sexual minorities
lgbtq
um and and in that bill
what is proposed is that you could
possibly preemptively
report to law enforcement if
um
one individual thinks that somebody else
is going to say something hateful or
post something offensive you can
preemptively
tattletail on them and law enforcement
could uh then surveil them for this and
and interestingly enough like this is so
authoritarian it's so sweeping and
um egregious that even twitter has
pushed back on the trudeau government
and has said that this could be used to
silence political opposition um
something very strange for twitter to
say obviously
and even even various ethnic minority
groups here in canada like the canadian
national muslims association has
pushed back against this bill and said
this could actually harm the very groups
that trudeau is trying to pander to with
this bill that's supposedly designed to
protect the feelings of racial and
ethnic minorities because apparently we
can't we can't take pushback online but
it's all just
more and more power in the way of
trudeau that the soul covered pandemic
has just fueled up his his behinds he's
gotten more and more power and he's
trying to
to uh
boost that even more with this online
social media censorship well you know
what folks we are a professional
organization around here so don't take
rav's word for all of that here's justin
trudeau himself
there is no question that the world is
changing rapidly and getting more
dangerous
in new ways than ever before when we
look at the prevalence of misinformation
of disinformation the way social media
has been weaponized both by uh foreign
actors uh and by people within canada
pushing extremist views trying to foment
anger and discord
whether it's
extremist ideology or right-wing
terrorism on the rise in canada
or
whether it's
examples like the illegal protests we
saw in in in the winter there are a
whole new set of challenges that we need
to be responding to and that's why we're
working closely with our national
security agencies working closely with
organizations like the the
canadian security establishment around
communications uh to make sure uh that
we are able to respond to these new
issues new new realities we need to do
it however in a way that continues to
defend freedom of speech freedom of
expression freedom to protest
to to legally protest
while at the same time we're taking on
more tools to keep canadians safe
because increasingly we're seeing that
things that start online
end up having impacts on the real world
justin trudeau i i can't my friend in
that moment we usually mute everybody we
didn't so i'll let you go first before i
let sarah jump in you just can't deal
with this guy anymore
it's it's audible torture it's
intellectual torture it's outright lies
this guy is now saying he's going to go
after misinformation he has been
responsible for putting out some of the
most egregious misinformation out of his
own mouth some of the most divisive
hateful comments ever he gets on his
podium when he's running for office
talking about the unvaccinated putting
at risk their kids and putting at risk
our kids those people putting us all at
risk he he is what he warns us about and
now he wants laws to basically protect
him and persecute whomever he disagrees
with and whomever he calls
misinformation it's
it's it's outrageous and i mean i'm i'm
glad i'm a reasonably polite person and
didn't say what i was thinking
it's nauseating to listen to
but viva he wears nice socks isn't that
important to you
it
he
he just it's it's incessant and it's
bill c-36 it's bill c-11 they want to
regulate the internet they basically
want to they want to criminalize any
speech that they don't like and that
happens to be independent media who call
trudeau for what he is
dishonest divisive and ultimately
wickedly unconstitutional